apple's store on fifth avenue in midtown
manhattan in new york city is one of the
most iconic stores in the world even if
you haven't personally been to new york
you must have seen the store's iconic
glass cube-shaped entrance on various
marketing materials and in the news in
this video we will explore the history
of apple's fifth avenue store and look
at why it has become such an iconic
landmark design and negotiation the
fifth avenue apple store is actually on
and beneath a public plaza in front of
the general motors building the glass
cube houses the entrance staircase and
the lift while the whole store is
located underground beneath the plaza
the general motors building and the
plaza were built in 1968 when the
previous savoy plaza that occupied the
space was demolished harry macklow
purchased the general motors building in
2003. one of his first plans to modify
his property was to monetize the large
plaza on fifth avenue the funny thing
was that back then architects and
industry insiders called the place a
problematic plaza this was because the
plaza was a large unused space with an
unused basement and manhattan is known
for its limited and precious real estate
but harry macklowe thought differently
he saw the space as the perfect spot for
a very unique store location in fact not
just any store harry was set on bringing
one particular company to the plaza
apple he was very persistent on the idea
of apple opening a store in the space
basically chewing on the ear of apple
vice president of real estate at the
time about it he finally got a meeting
with apple ceo steve jobs in november
2003. he managed to convince steve jobs
to open an apple store in the unused
plaza on his property and not just any
store apple would be opening a flagship
store that would be open for business 24
7. that meeting was attended by several
architects and designers including
bolden ziewinski jackson jackson had
previously designed the soho apple store
steve jobs pitched an idea of a 40-foot
glass cube at the center of the site
while macklow wanted a glass pavilion
close to the street jobs and macklow
initially didn't agree on the design
macklo thought steve's idea for a
40-foot glass cube wasn't a viable
option it would be too large for the
sight and also break zoning restrictions
he wasn't able to convince steve with
words so he used another approach he had
a mock-up of the 40-foot cube
constructed in the late night on the
plaza apple executives viewed the
structure at 2 am in the cover of
darkness they agreed the cube was too
large and makla was right macklow then
ordered the first mock-up structure to
be dismantled which revealed a 30-foot
cube within the first cube apple
executives approved of the second
mock-up the store was then developed in
secret and a prototype model was quietly
built in a warehouse near the apple
campus in cupertino california fifth
avenue store opens its doors the fifth
avenue apple store opened its doors to
the public for the first time on may 19
2006. at the time it would be apple's
147th store even though there were
concerns about the store not performing
very well it blew everyone's
expectations when the sales numbers came
in for the store's first year the fifth
avenue apple store had on average
generated sales of one million dollars
per day in its first year that was
completely mind-blowing at the time
first renovation the fifth avenue apple
store got its first retouching and
renovation in 2011. in june apple began
a five-month renovation of the store the
renovation would cost apple about 6.7
million dollars the renovation
simplified the store's glass cube
entrance way previously the store's
glass cube entrance way was made from 90
panels the renovation simplified this
glass structure to be made from just 15
panels of glass the renovation also saw
some retouching and minor changes to the
surrounding plaza the store didn't
change much on the inside though but
throughout these changes apple
maintained the unique look the fifth
avenue apple store was known for second
renovation from 2017 to 2019 apple
closed the main fifth avenue store as
they began reconstruction on the site
this renovation was on a much larger
scale as compared to the last renovation
luckily apple managed to keep its
presence in the area even though this
particular store was closed the fao
schwartz store in the gm building right
next to apple store was available to
rent so apple moved their store to this
new space inside the building the
renovation and reconstruction of the
store involved plans to double the store
space they also raised the ceiling of
the store by digging deeper into the
ground there were also other significant
changes made to the store apple spared
no expense to make their most famous
store a talk of the ages how the current
store looks the most exciting thing
added to the store building was the
addition of 62 circular frosted
skylights added to the plaza area these
skylights bless the underground plaza
with natural light from above this added
more openness to the store's ambiance on
the store ceiling new tunable white leds
were added that would automatically move
between warm and cool tones based on the
time of day to make everything feel more
natural to both sides of the cube apple
added 18 new contraptions called sky
lenses these were shiny metal seats that
also happen to provide a bird's-eye view
down into the store so people in the
plaza can look down and watch everything
happening in the underground store
apple's infamous cube entrance was also
redone but apple also decided to add new
entrances to the store even with the new
entrances the most popular one customers
use is the main entrance with a spiral
staircase that is completely made from
stainless steel previously this
staircase was made from glass the apple
fifth avenue experience with the latest
iteration of the iconic apple store
designers decided to go with a more
community space vibe for the store they
started with planting a lot of trees and
foliage throughout the store to give a
fresh look the plants give the space a
more natural and refreshing look
presently the store also has huge
displays with seating arrangements for
presentations and classes some of the
walls are entirely covered with
vegetation and benches placed next to
them for customers customers can sit
here and charge their phones via
wireless chargers apple is going for a
whole campus and community shopping
experience there are no checkout lines
instead a store rep will come to you and
check you out on his ipad apple even
allows customers to check themselves out
via the app store apple just doesn't
want this store to sell products but
also sell the apple experience itself so
customers keep coming back for it this
is why you will see things like a
special experience room where apple
showcases how their products and
services work together and special
classes and presentations about new
things apple is doing you will also see
this philosophy resonate in how the
apple store at fifth avenue operates the
store employs 900 people most of whom
are bilingual the team collectively
speaks about 36 languages ever since
apple's fifth avenue store opened its
doors to customers in 2006 half the
staff which was 300 at the time was
dedicated to offering free assistance to
customers on how to use apple products
apple just didn't want this to be
another one of their regular outlets
they wanted this store to be a classroom
to get into the apple ecosystem the
store is always open to customers with
no hours or days closed it is the only
apple store with 24 7 and 365 open
schedules this is in line with new york
city's infamous nightlife the legacy at
the store's opening the new york times
reported that the fifth avenue apple
store will burnish the company's
reputation for clever design other
newspapers had a more negative view of
the thing they considered that the store
had offered many costly indulgences to
its customers that would not be able to
generate enough revenue since half the
staff was just there to help teach the
customers to use apple products and not
sell apple products this notion was
proven false after the first year of
this store's operation as this store
alone was generating 1 million dollars
in sales each day for its first year the
fifth avenue apple store is also the
most photographed landmark in new york
city it is also the fifth most geotagged
site in new york city and 28th most
worldwide the apple store on fifth
avenue was geotagged in more photographs
than the statue of liberty when the
store reopened in 2019 an author for
architectural digest wrote for many it's
now impossible to imagine the southeast
corner of central park without it this
is the kind of timeless legacy that the
store has garnered for itself these days
the first image that comes to any apple
fan's head when someone talks about an
apple store is the apple store on 5th
avenue the store and its unique
architecture have become synonymous with
the apple brand itself the fifth avenue
store was so inspiring that it would
later inspire store designs for other
apple stores in the u.s these include
the apple walnut street store in
philadelphia and apple upper west side
store in new york city